without upsetting some of your audience
I think the generation Zed need to have
a bit of a wake-up call they have a
different view different perspective
where they want everything happy
harmonious you know work-life balance
you know my mental health must be
amazing all those things which are great
they need to make sure they still work
hard and a lot of recruiters fall into
the Generation Z bracket you cannot
succeed if you don't work hard there is
a numbers game to this when gets
hard you have to increase the numbers
you can get to a point where you're
billing 300 Grand a year and you kind of
got a couple of clients and you know
it's going well you're probably not
applying yourself as much as you would
have done to build up to that point
you're probably into a routine if you
lose two of those clients and you're
suddenly down to billing 100 Grand a
year you can't sit back and go it's all
right it'll change you have to go back
to what you did to get those clients and
to get that position you have to do a
lot of everything so work hard and be
consistent people do something for a
week and go that didn't work and I'll do
that again so I think the three things I
would say to anybody now that wants to
be successful work hard do lots of
everything have variety so mix it up and
be consistent